SPEAKER 1: Bradley J Birzer
is the Russell Amos Kirk
professor in American
studies at Hillsdale College.
He earned his BA
from the University
of Notre Dame and his MA and
PhD from Indiana University.
He served on the Board of
the Free Enterprise Institute
and the Center for
Cultural Renewal.
He also serves as
fellow or scholar
at the Foundation for Economic
Education, the Intercollegiate
Studies Institute, the
McConnell Center, and the Center
for Economic Personalism.
He has written for
numerous publications,
including The
Imaginative Conservative,
a site he co-founded, Ignatius
Insight, National Review,
and Catholic World Report.
He is the author of several
books, including J.R.R.
Tolkien's Sanctifying Myth--
Understanding Middle
Earth, American Cicero--
The Life of Charles Carroll, and
In Defense of Andrew Jackson.
Please welcome Dr. Birzer.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Well,
good afternoon, everybody.
I am very, very honored to be
here and to start off this CCA.
I've never been able to--
I've never been asked
to speak at a CCA
as an actual participant
during the lectures.
My department chair,
who's been very gracious
and has been Dean
of Faculty, has
asked me to speak on
faculty roundtables before,
but this is the first time
I actually get to speak.
And I get to speak as
the first speaker, which
is really, really exciting
in all kinds of ways.
So, Jason, thank you so
much for that introduction.
And I also would like to think
Matt Bell for inviting me,
being the head of the CCAs.
Doug Jeffrey, Vice President
for External Affairs,
also for inviting me.
And for the entire staff
at external affairs.
Obviously, we would not be here
without what they're doing.
This is fantastic.
I do also want to point
out over there, though,
I can't see right now,
because of the lighting.
My beautiful wife, my
lovely wife, Dedra,
is right over here.
And she's been bouncing--
or allowing me to bounce ideas
off of her for several years
now actually, maybe more
than we would care to admit.
And she's been great.
I also want to point out
my very lovely depart--
not lovely, sorry, my
manly department chair,
Mark Kalthoff, back
there, as well,
for being very supportive.
And I just-- I have to
point out two other people.
Tom Connor is here, and he will
be on the faculty roundtable.
And I actually have nothing
good to say about him.
I just want to
make sure that when
it comes to his turn to
talk about my speech,
he knows I recognized him.
So we will leave it at that.
OK.
On a very serious note,
as many of you may know,
when Andrew Jackson
took the oath of office
for the very first time
on March 4 of 1829,
he did so wearing all black.
He was still lamenting
the very recent loss
of his wife, his partner, his
absolute intellectual equal.
He also-- when he gave his talk,
when he gave his inaugural,
he bowed twice to
the American people--
once when he started and once
when he finished his talks.
And both times he
recognized that they were
the true sovereigns of America.
This was not affectation
or theater on his part.
One of the things that
astounded me absolutely
in getting to write
on Andrew Jackson
is how unbelievably
honest he was
and how unbelievably dedicated
he was to the American people.
So in 2017-- and I don't want to
make this too autobiographical
about me.
But in 2017, I got asked
through John Miller, who
teaches here at the college--
he was asked by Harry Crocker,
who was the head then,
of Regnery Publishing--
if they knew somebody who could
write a very quick and short
biography of Andrew Jackson.
I'd been teaching Andrew
Jackson during a class
that we have here at Hillsdale
College for the last 20, 21
years, since 1999.
I'd been teaching a course
called Jacksonian America.
And throughout most
of the time that I
had the privilege of
teaching that course-- which
I absolutely loved.
There are incredible figures
like Ralph Waldo Emerson
and Henry David Thoreau
and John Quincy Adams.
During much of that,
I always taught
Andrew Jackson is the bad guy.
He was the first really
strong executive.
This was a person
who tried to distort
what the founders wanted.
He was our seventh president.
He was the first non-classically
educated president.
He was kind of a
country bumpkin.
He was an Indian murderer.
And I taught him,
basically, as that
for roughly 18
years of my career
here at Hillsdale College.
So when John Miller
and Harry Crocker
asked me to write
about Andrew Jackson,
I was kind of taken aback.
I wasn't quite
sure if I could do
this, because I know
that they wanted a pretty
positive biography, especially
because Donald Trump had been
making all kinds of claims very
recently, especially on Andrew
Jackson's 250th birthday,
about the greatness
of that President.
And I knew that Regnery
wanted to kind of compare
Andrew Jackson to Donald Trump.
And I decided to
go ahead, because I
got from Harry Crocker
an assurance that I
could write whatever
I wanted, as long as I
was able to back it up.
I found very quickly that I fell
in love with Andrew Jackson,
almost immediately.
Of all the people I've had
the privilege to write on,
and I've written only upon
people that I really like,
I found that I got to
know Andrew Jackson better
than almost every
other figure that I've
been able to write about.
And the reason was because
he speaks so openly.
There is no duplicity in
his language, in his mind.
I actually think it
would go constitutionally
against the very character
and the very soul
and person of Andrew
Jackson to be duplicitous.
Now, he's also the
most brutal person
I have ever come
across in my own life,
in terms of studying
someone this intimately.
So he was both incredibly
honest and incredibly brutal.
And I had to come
to grips with that.
What is it about
this man, and what
is it about his brutality,
that in many ways
plays into his honesty?
And what is it about his honesty
that plays into his brutality?
What I wasn't expecting,
and partly because I
was in grad school during the
1990s, what I wasn't expecting
was the vigorous
pushback that I was
going to get from academics
in even quasi-praising
any aspect of Andrew Jackson.
When I was in college--
I graduated college in 1990 and
I finished grad school in 1999.
When I was in college
and graduate school,
Andrew Jackson was
still very well regarded
within the history profession.
In fact, a poll among
historians in 1996
revealed that most
American historians still
regarded Andrew Jackson
as one of the five
most important and best
presidents in the United
States.
And that's amazing, because
if you go back now in 2020
and you were to ask
historians what they
think of Andrew Jackson,
he'll be probably
in the bottom 10 to 15.
His star has fallen
dramatically.
And I was told, in
no uncertain terms,
both in interviews on the
radio, as well as in critiques
of my own book, that defending
Andrew Jackson was no better
than defending Adolf Hitler.
I do not exaggerate.
I was told this several times.
Of course, they never
bring up Stalin.
And I thought, well,
if you're going
to get nasty, bring Stalin
up, but they didn't all right.
He's too left, so only Hitler
would do in a criticism.
But I was told that Andrew
Jackson was a rapist.
That's not true.
I was told he was a murderer.
And I was told he was
an ethnic cleanser.
That's not true.
Fascinating what so many people
believe about Andrew Jackson.
And what struck, me even in
the pushback on Andrew Jackson,
was how absolutely
mythic this character is.
He is either in
American history,
and has been, either a kind of
heroic demigod, the great flag
embodied, or he
has been a demon.
In his own days, he
was called a knight
in buckskin, the Napoleon
of the woods, Old Hickory.
And the greatest title
that any American
could have held prior
to the 20th century,
he was the hero of New Orleans.
Those were all very
nice accolades.
These were great things that
we saw about his character.
And I can't help but
think that there's
a kind of American
stereotype, in the good way,
about who Andrew Jackson was.
He is like this kind of
unrealistic, but fascinating
American character.
He is really the
frontier personified.
I couldn't help but think of
Johnny Ringo in Stagecoach,
that great John Ford movie.
And I couldn't help but think of
the innocence of Johnny Ringo.
For those of you've
seen Stagecoach--
and if you haven't
recently, you should,
one of the great classics
in American cinema.
Johnny Ringo, this
young gunfighter,
finds himself on a stage
coach with a whole variety
of different people from
different parts of society.
And one of the persons on the
stage coach is a prostitute.
And Johnny Ringo
doesn't get that.
He just knows that she's a
fancy woman and she's a woman,
and he needs to treat
her in a certain way.
The other woman
on the stage coach
is deeply offended by this.
I'll come back to why this
is important, especially
for Andrew Jackson.
Or I think of John Wayne,
again, as Ethan Edwards
in The Searchers,
another John Ford movie.
John Ford and John Wayne
understood something
about this unique character--
the man who loses, the man who
struggles no matter the cost.
But no matter the loss and
no matter the struggle, he
continues to fight
for what's right,
because he knows that's
at the essence of what it
means to be an American male.
But we could jump forward
a little bit, as well.
And now I'm probably revealing
my own age, because I certainly
wasn't around when Stagecoach
or The Searchers came out,
but I was very much alive and
rather in love with a science
fiction story called
Firefly in the early 2000s,
about 20 years ago.
And for those of you
who've seen that,
it is a Western set in space.
And the main figure
is a John Wayne kind
of figure by the name
of Malcolm Reynolds.
And there's a great moment
in the pilot of that show.
The show only lasted,
I think, 16 episodes.
They did 13 for the pilot
season and then another three
and it failed.
And then they made a movie.
It's unfortunate that it failed,
but it's one of those things,
I'm glad it existed at all.
But there's a moment where
a young doctor comes up
to the captain of the
ship, the Firefly--
or the Serenity, a
Firefly-class ship.
And this character, Malcolm
Reynolds, is challenged.
And the doctor says, after
all the violence I've seen,
are you going to shoot me?
And Malcolm Reynolds
says something to him
that's incredible.
And Andrew Jackson
could have said it.
He says, "You don't
know me, son, so
let me explain it to you once.
If I ever kill you, you'll be
awake, you'll be facing me,
and you'll be armed."
Now, that's the ultimate
American male statement.
In terms of
understanding what it
means to be a small-r
republican, a believer
in a republic, and
to be an American,
I think that captures
the essence of it.
Now, it's not a normal
statement and yet, it's
unbelievably American.
And for me, this is what
Andrew Jackson was all about.
So I want to make
five points today
in talking about character and
leadership in Andrew Jackson.
So Andrew Jackson is born in
1767, and he dies in 1845.
It's a pretty amazing life,
when you think about everything
that he went through.
He was born into absolute
poverty, Scotch-Irish poverty,
in every way.
He was able to work his
way up into the world,
even though he had lost
the entirety of his family
by the time he was 14.
He was able to work his way
up out of poverty and into not
just respectable middle
class, but Southern gentry
status in Nashville,
Tennessee, which I would argue
was as Western
and frontier as it
was southern during the
age of Andrew Jackson--
again, those two
qualities coming together,
that violence of the
frontier and that
honor of being a
Scotch-Irish American.
But I want to point out five
things about Andrew Jackson,
as we think about
him and his career.
Number one, I think
very importantly,
he was, all of his life,
a small-r Republican.
He believed in the
essence of a republic,
he was a Presbyterian,
and he was Scotch-Irish.
And I think in many ways that
identification of his ethnicity
and his religion
and his politics
reveals much about
who the man was.
His mother, as I mentioned,
died when he was young.
He was only 14.
And his mother died because she
was nursing American soldiers
during the American
Revolution and caught a fever
and was not able to overcome it.
But she did leave some
advice for Andrew,
whom she hoped would grow up
to be a Presbyterian minister.
It was actually one reason that
they saved up their money, very
little that they
had, for Andrew to be
able to go to a
liberal arts college
when he was a young man.
He didn't use the
money for that.
It went for other things.
Andrew Jackson did
end up having somewhat
of a classical education,
but as he himself said,
everything that he
ever needed to know,
he learned by reading
stories of William Wallace,
the great Scottish nationalist.
And there's something to
that, especially when we
think about Andrew Jackson.
But here's what his
mother wrote him,
before she died, as
a piece of advice.
So point number one
being Republican,
Scotch-Irish, Presbyterian, and
being the son of this woman.
"Andrew, if I should
never see you again,
I wish you to remember and
treasure up some things that I
have already said to you.
In this world, you always
have to make your own way.
To do that, you have
to have friends.
You must make friends
by being honest.
And you must keep them
by being steadfast.
You must keep in
mind that friends
worth having will
in the long run
expect as much from you
as they give to you.
"To forget an obligation or to
be ungrateful for a kindness
is a base crime, not
merely a fault or a sin,
but an actual crime.
Men guilty of this crime sooner
or later suffer the penalty.
In personal conduct, be always
polite, but never obsequious.
None will respect you more than
you will ever respect yourself.
Avoid quarrels as
long as you can
without yielding to imposition,
but sustain your manhood
always.
Never bring a suit of law
for assault or battery
or defamation to a courtroom.
The law affords no
remedy for such outrages
that can satisfy the
feelings of a true man."
Everybody catch that?
You beat the snot out of
your opponent on the street.
You don't take him to court.
This is what it means to
be a real man of the law.
"Never wound the
feelings of another.
Never brook once an outrage
upon your own feelings.
If you ever have to
vindicate your feelings
or defend your
honor, do it calmly.
And then, if angry,
wait until your wrath
cools before you proceed."
Now, what motherly
advice, right?
There we have it.
And Andrew loves this.
This is everything to him.
And one of the most
fascinating things
I found in going through
the life of Andrew Jackson
was how much, to an almost
surrealistic degree,
he respected women.
Now, this is a
great thing, right?
We should respect women.
Men should respect women.
But Jackson took
this to the point
where his mother
and his wife, who
was his intellectual equal
in every way and his partner,
he took it so far that I have
never seen anyone in history
think so highly of a
woman, except for maybe
Roman Catholics in the way
they approach the Virgin Mary.
And I say that without
any kind of recrimination,
just straightforward.
Jackson had a great
reverence for women.
So if you remember, I
brought up a little bit ago,
Johnny Ringo on the stagecoach.
We find letters in Andrew
Jackson's collected letters
where he wrote to the
prostitutes of Nashville,
Tennessee inviting
them to the town balls,
not as dates, but as
equals, because they, too,
were citizens or at least
residents of Nashville.
Wasn't a joke.
It wasn't meant in any
way to be derogatory.
Andrew truly believed that
this was how you treated women.
And we could say, and
this was something
that was brought
up against Andrew
Jackson in his own
lifetime and today,
well, what about Black women?
He was a slave owner.
We have the testimony
of one of his slaves,
Hannah, who said that
every time Andrew
Jackson came to the plantation,
everybody celebrated.
He solved problems.
He served as a judge.
He treated all of his
slaves with respect.
He rolled up his shirt
sleeves and worked with them
in every way.
And not only that, but when
Rachel Jackson passed away
in 1829 and Jackson
had to leave his estate
to go up to Washington
to be president,
he left Hannah, his
Black slave, in charge
of the estate for the eight
years that he was gone.
It's pretty impressive.
Kind of complicates our
view of slavery, doesn't it?
There it is.
Very, very interesting.
Point number two
about Andrew Jackson.
As I mentioned earlier,
Jackson was as honest
as he was violent.
And one of the things that
shocked me to no end--
and I will admit,
I'm from Kansas.
I'm a Volga German,
Russian-German stock.
My family refused to fight
during World War I, which
my wife's family still
likes to tease me about,
because they have
fought in every,
every encounter America's been
in, I think going back to,
like, Queen Anne's war.
So they have been in
everything and very proudly so.
My family has done everything
to dodge war in every way.
So this is not from my
background in Kansas.
But I think about the
complex set of rules
that went around
dueling during the 1800s
and how complicated this was.
Andrew Jackson once said,
for malicious slander,
all men are answered
only at the bar of honor.
Now, think about what
his mother told him.
Anytime you're wronged,
you never take it to court.
You settle it in the street.
That's what real men do.
And that's exactly what
Andrew Jackson did.
But there's something
about Jackson's duels
that are absolutely fascinating.
The duels dictated that no
people ever of unequal worth
could challenge one
another in a duel.
And Jackson has in his own
letters and his diaries that
when younger men who were
clearly trying to make
their way in society and prove
their worth within Scotch-Irish
society--
when they would
challenge Jackson,
Jackson would
actually go up to them
in the street with his
cane and just beat them.
[LAUGHTER]
He would tell them, you're
not worthy of a duel,
but someday you will be.
And it was actually-- to
be caned by Andrew Jackson
was regarded as a good thing.
And here's why.
Because it meant that you
would mean something someday,
even if you don't yet.
If Jackson ignored you, that
was the worst thing possible.
Here's one of the most
interesting comments.
And I'll give you two stories
about Jackson and dueling.
When he was in the US Senate--
and he only served
twice in the US Senate
and neither for a full
term, just a couple
of years in the 1790s and
then again in the 1820s.
He just served for
about two years each.
But the first time
that he was in,
he was in during John
Adams's administration.
And he was absolutely disgusted
by a fight that was going
on-- not a real fight, but
a political argument going
on the floor of the Senate--
that lasted for 16 days.
And Jackson writes in his
diary, "I don't get this.
These men are a feat.
This is all sticks and spittle.
We have spent 16 days of the
people's money spending $10,000
for this debate.
And what an absolute disgrace.
They could have easily
solved it by a quick duel
outside of Congress."
[LAUGHTER]
Now, he means this.
This is not a joke
on his part, right?
This is the way
men settle things.
And I have to admit,
and I don't consider
myself an extremely
violent person,
but when I looked
at how complicated
the rules were in society and
how detailed the instructions
were on who you could fight
and who you couldn't fight,
there is something honorable
in what Jackson is advocating.
I'm not calling for a return--
please, I can see people now.
"Hillsdale professor calls
for a return to dueling."
This is not what I'm doing.
But I do want to put it into
the context of the times,
that there is something
fascinating about what's
going on.
But here's my
favorite challenge.
Andrew Jackson, as you may
know, was extremely intelligent,
but not very well educated.
And one of the funniest things
about going through his letters
is he never spells the same
word the same way twice, right?
And I think he would
have considered
it a badge of
dishonor had he been
able to spell consistently.
But he would write these
challenges in the Nashville
newspaper where he would
say, because of this person's
actions, I challenge this person
to a duel for whatever reason.
And he would list it.
And then he would say,
I call on this person
to give me a time and a date.
And one of the persons that
he got into a fight with
was the governor, John Sevier.
And so they were trying
to figure out a time.
And they kept sending-- and
I've seen all these notes.
They're hilarious.
They keep sending these notes
back to each other saying,
well, I think we should
fight by long sword.
We'll do it at this
place at this time.
Other one will write back, no,
long sword's not appropriate.
I say we use this
caliber pistol.
We'll do it at this time.
And this went on for weeks.
And Jackson got
really frustrated.
And so he finally
published in the newspaper,
"To all whom shall see
this, present greetings.
Know ye that I, Andrew
Jackson, do pronounce, publish,
and declare to the world
that the excellency John
Sevier, your governor,
captain general,
commander in chief of the land
and Naval forces of the state
of Tennessee is a base coward.
[LAUGHTER]
"He will basely insult,
but he has not the courage
to repair the wound."
Now, there is the
final statement.
And so Sevier agrees.
And they come up on a time.
And Jackson is anxious
about this duel.
And they have to duel right on
the Tennessee-Kentucky border.
They don't want to
be either exactly
in Kentucky or Tennessee
in case the law
decides to get involved.
So they pick this spot on the
Kentucky-Tennessee border.
Jackson shows up early.
He's got his number two.
You always have a second
with you, in case you fall,
who can pick up the fight.
And he sees, about
15 minutes late,
Sevier riding in on a horse
with a friend, his number two.
And Jackson is furious,
because the guy's late.
And so Jackson pulls his cane.
Remember the cane?
He pulls his cane out,
and he charges Sevier,
charges him across this field.
And Sevier is so
befuddled by this
that he tries to
pull his sword out,
but in the act of trying
to pull his sword out,
he falls off his horse.
And he falls onto the
ground on top of his sword,
and his sword breaks in two.
Jackson comes up
to him and says,
I see you've removed your sword.
I consider this duel satisfied.
[LAUGHTER]
They shook hands, rode
back to Nashville together,
and became constant
allies for the rest
of each of their career.
[LAUGHTER]
How do we explain this in
politically correct 2020,
right?
Can you imagine on Twitter?
[LAUGHS] Oh, you scoundrel.
All right, point number
three, and specifically about
the context of this great CCA
on character and leadership
in the military.
One of the most
interesting things
about Andrew Jackson that I
think we often don't remember
about him is that he actually
had a great animosity
towards the standing
army, even though he
was a general within
the standing army.
He wrote constantly
throughout his life.
He didn't write-- he
wrote lots of letters.
He didn't write a lot of public
documents, but he did a few.
And in these statements that he
wrote about the standing army,
he had kind of the old fashioned
small-r republican notion that
a true republic will be
defended by its Navy--
it can be permanent-- but
never by a standing army, which
is almost always the tool of
oppression, as he thought.
He said, there are
really only two reasons
to call up the army.
And you never have it
for more than two years.
And this is in the Constitution.
We know that no bill that
gives revenue to the army
can last for more
than two years.
There are no such
restrictions on the Navy,
but there is that in
the US constitution.
Jackson said there are only
two reasons we would ever
call up the standing army.
Number one, if the
Indians are harassing us.
Or number two, if
the Europeans are.
He's not expecting anyone
else, but if the Europeans
or the Indians.
And even then, when we
call up to standing army,
we always put limitations on it.
And we always make sure
that the militia is
superior to the standing army.
Here he is an 1805, during his
July 4th toast in Tennessee.
He says, and this
is toast number--
oh, I'm sorry, I
did not write this.
It's toast number seven.
And it actually mattered,
the number of toast,
because I'll read you
seven and then 11.
So toast number seven.
"To the militias of
the United States,
the surest bulwark of freedom."
And then number 11.
"To the Army of
the United States,
which we must
always remember can
be doomed to
persecution and tyranny
under a government of laws
to satiate the private spleen
of any would-be despot."
So that's pretty amazing.
We're praising the
army, but not really,
because we don't know exactly
what that army is going to do.
Five years later, in 1810,
he explained his own position
in a letter to the
governor of Tennessee.
He says, "Our independence
and liberty as a people
was not obtained
without expense.
It was dearly bought
with blood and treasure.
And it must be preserved.
The pence on this subject
can never be counted,
but the only real and
substantial defense
of a free people is
the organized militia.
This is always," and
I quote from Jackson,
"in contrast with the
corruption manifested
at all times in
our regular army."
And this has been verified
by our constitution, which
only allows the two-year
funding for things in the army.
In 1812 and 1813, when
Andrew Jackson called up
his own private militia and
state army within Tennessee,
he told them that no matter
what-- he assured them,
he would not allow
the federal government
to federalize them in any way.
He said to his men
in March of 1812,
there will be no drafts
or compulsory levies.
And if they are made, there
will be a simple invitation
to those who buy into that idea
to leave to us the fighting.
So if you've been drafted, if
you're here against your will,
we'll ask you to leave.
Jackson, when he was told
by the Secretary of War
that he must federalize
his troops, he refused.
And he said, this is
not what I promised
the parents of these young men.
These young men are here
strictly because they
believe the fight is correct.
And he refused to follow the
order of John Armstrong, then
the Secretary of War.
And he said, I would remind
you of your own army's success.
Was it not under
the US Army Command
of William Hull
at Detroit in 1812
that you surrendered a third
of our forces to the British?
Where is your glorious army?
And by what right do you
have to regulate my militia?
He says, "A nobler feeling
should impel us to action.
Who are we?
What are we going to fight for?
Are we the slaves of George
III--" this is in 1813.
"Are we the slaves of George
III or the military conscripts
of Napoleon or the frozen
peasants of the Russian czar?
No.
We are freeborn sons of
the Republic of America,
the citizens of
the only republic
now existing in the world and
the only people on earth who
possess rights,
liberty, and property
which they dare call their own."
It's amazing.
And think about that.
And I hope-- this is one
of those things we rarely
teach in our classrooms.
I hope we have to
understand and explain
that this is a different world.
And when Jackson is
against the military,
in this kind of audience that I
have right here in front of me,
this is odd to us.
But when we imagine what the
history of standing armies
had been at the time
that Jackson speaks
in 1812 and 1813, we
can understand why
he's so hesitant about this.
But he takes this even further.
When he is inaugurated
on March 4 of 1829,
he will not allow any military
officers to be present.
And if they're present,
they may not be in uniform.
But he does invite all the
militias of the present day
and of all those who fought
during the Revolutionary War
to come and parade.
And he walks with them
during his inaugural.
That's astounding in
all kinds of ways.
OK, point number four.
Well, despite this,
Andrew Jackson
is one of the greatest
victors in US history.
And we can think about what
he did on January 8 of 1815.
And I would remind everyone
here that Jackson's force was
a force of only
2,000 that he had
at the Battle of New Orleans.
And it was Jackson
almost alone who
understood that
after the British had
invaded in the Great Lakes
and then up the Chesapeake,
their next venue
would be Mississippi.
Very few people believed that
was going to be the case.
We were in the middle of
signing a peace in the fall
and early winter of
1814 with Britain.
Britain had just
concluded hostilities
by defeating Napoleon.
And we thought this was it.
Jackson knew better.
He knew that the British
would do one last thing.
We also know this, that when
the British were given orders
and there were 14,000 troops
being carried on 60 ships
under the leadership of Ned
Pakenham coming from Britain,
these were all Napoleonic
soldiers battle-hardened.
These were not draftees.
These were not new recruits.
These were men who had
seen much action in Europe
throughout the Napoleonic Wars.
And they had express
permission from both Parliament
and the king that, when
they were to attack,
it was not to be
a harassment raid.
It was to be an attack
to reclaim property
all along the Mississippi River.
That's something we often
forget about in history.
This was not meant to
be some harassment run.
The British were here for
blood and for our soil.
And Jackson understood this.
He knew that this was coming.
And so he, in what would
resemble modern trench
warfare, what we will see at
Petersburg during the Civil War
or what we'll see at
the Battle of the Somme
and other great
battles in World War I,
He created massive trenches
waiting for the British
to come.
And again, I'll remind
us of that force.
Jackson has just a
little over 2,000 men--
all recruits, all free.
He refused to allow any
draftees with him at all.
He would find that abhorrent.
So he has only about
2,000 men, but they
are in great battle-hardened
mode behind these trenches
in these dugouts.
Well, one of my
favorite historians,
who was actually a
journalist before he became
a historian, Paul Johnson,
writes in his excellent book
from 1991, The Birth
of The Modern--
he describes how terrible
the British were in executing
this plan at New Orleans.
He says, "The Great Duke
of Wellington, Pakenham,
had married his
sister Catherine,
but that was the closest
that that man had ever
gotten to any military mastery.
"Money and connections had
made Pakenham a Major before he
was 17 and a Colonel at age 21.
There was no question
of his courage.
Serving as a Major General under
his brother-in-law at Salamanca
in 1812, he had been
given the chance
when Wellington told him to
take his division straight
at the French center with the
words, now is your time, Ned.
Ned broke through
the French line.
And this, Wellington said in
a dispatch, won the battle,
though he admitted, quote,
'Pakenham may not be
the brightest of geniuses.'"
[LAUGHTER]
He launched a full frontal
assault on Jackson's position
on January 8 of 1815.
Andrew Jackson in his own
report says that he had about 10
of his own men killed and
about 10 wounded total--
20 casualties out of 2,000.
The British that day lost
1,500 Marines and another 500
who were taken prisoner.
Imagine that.
There were close to
44 bodies that were so
decimated in the Gulf of
Mexico that they could not
find the remains of them.
They couldn't identify.
This is incredible.
And what do we have and
what comes out of this?
And this is where,
no matter what,
even if we remembered Andrew
Jackson for nothing else,
he is the hero of New Orleans.
Was he lucky?
Maybe.
Was he smart?
Did he win?
He won, brutally.
He won.
And so what does
Paul Johnson say?
Paul Johnson, who
is British himself,
says, this was the great moment
in Anglo-American relations.
It was at this moment alone
that the British finally
took us seriously as a country.
It was at this moment that the
great Anglo-American Alliance,
which had lasted, and
still does up until 2020--
but certainly at the time that
Johnson wrote this in 1991,
this was the beginning of our
mutual respect with each other.
And you think about
Andrew Jackson.
He's now as great
as William Wallace.
He's now as great as James Wolf.
He is truly one of
the great generals
in history at that point.
And more than any
other title he had,
the title that meant
the most to him
and the one that meant
the most to Americans,
always, was that he was
the hero of New Orleans.
Finally, point number five.
And I'll conclude with this, and
we'll open it up for questions.
One of my favorite things
about Andrew Jackson--
so today-- you'll have
to forgive me for this--
but I wore-- and I don't know
how many of you can see this.
My grandfather, who was
the best man I ever knew,
he died in 1982.
But I wore his campaign button
for Dwight D Eisenhower from--
I don't know if it's
from '52 or '56,
but it's from one
of those elections.
And I've had it with me.
I've never worn it before.
This is the first
time I've worn it.
And I thought, we're here
to talk about character.
We're here to talk
about American generals.
What better figure other than
Andrew Jackson than Dwight D.
Eisenhower?
What a great thing.
And I grew up in Kansas.
I've been to the Eisenhower
museum a million times.
So you guys will
please forgive me.
I've already given you
Jackson's views on the military.
And they're probably
not so well taken,
necessarily, in this audience
and understandably so.
But I would also
give another view
of Andrew Jackson and something
that I think we often forget,
but should remember.
At the end of Andrew Jackson's
life-- he died in 1845,
as I mentioned earlier--
people, his friends, offered
to build him a mausoleum so
that they could dedicate at
least some memorial to him
as hero of New Orleans and as
President of the United States.
And Jackson writes them back.
And he says, "I am
so honored that you
would want to remember
me after my death,
but I must decline any memorial.
My own republican feelings and
my principles of republicanism
forbid it.
And the simplicity of our
way of life as a republic
should forbid it.
True virtue cannot exist where
pomp and parade are governing
passions.
It can only dwell
with the people--
the great laboring
and producing classes
that form the bone and the
sinew of our republic."
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you, Dr. Birzer.
BRADLEY J BIRZER: You're
welcome, wherever you are.
[LAUGHTER]
I really can't see.
SPEAKER 2: I'm right over here.
BRADLEY J BIRZER:
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: We now have
time for Q&A. Please
make your way to the microphone
if you have a question.
AUDIENCE: Doctor,
could you say something
about the Bank of
the United States?
BRADLEY J BIRZER: I'm sorry
could you repeat that, please?
AUDIENCE: Could you say
something about Jackson
and the Bank of
the United States?
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Oh, sure.
Yeah.
So the question about Jackson
and the Bank of the United
States is a great one.
Because obviously--
and it's not something
I focused on, since we're
doing with military history,
but it's related.
Andrew Jackson in his honesty--
and I think we could
probably debate this,
but people at the Mises
Institute and Ron Paul
would agree with this.
Jackson's argument
was essentially
that money must be real.
If it's not actual
specie, that is,
if it's not based on a
physical commodity, it's a lie.
This was part of
Jackson's honesty.
He was a gold man in every way.
Gold, silver, whatever it is
that we wanted to trade in,
but it had to be a commodity.
And so from the very beginning
of the First Bank of the United
States, Jackson had
vehemently opposed it.
When he was a young man,
he opposed the Second Bank
of the United States.
And of course, when
he's president,
he can actually do
something about this.
And when the Whigs
tried to outmaneuver him
during his first administration
and have the bank come up
four years early for renewal,
for a 20-year renewal,
Jackson uses this to
solidify his own power.
In fact, it in some
ways, Jackson really
becomes Jackson as
president after his victory
against the Second Bank
of the United States.
And he makes two arguments.
He says, number one,
ultimately, this is a lie.
Paper money is always
and everywhere a lie.
Even if you could
have paper money
effective for a
certain amount of time,
it will always become corrupt
at some point, because it's not
worth anything.
It's only worth what
we state it's worth.
And therefore, it can't
have any longevity.
But the second point
he made to this
was a very interesting
one, and one I
think that those of us
who love the free market
should remember.
His argument was that power
rarely benefits the poor.
It almost always
benefits the rich.
And what was the Second Bank of
the United States founded for?
Not to create equality among
the peoples of America,
but to give privilege
to the wealthy.
And he actually argued through
much of his own arguments
on government privilege that
that's the thing that we most
be concerned about.
The poor will always be here.
They will come and go.
But they'll never really
have any long-term say
over the government, he
thought, but the rich would.
And we had to be
very careful of that.
But he's coming from a radically
laissez-faire argument on that,
which I find very interesting.
So thank you for that question.
AUDIENCE: Can you comment
on the Trail of Tears?
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Is
that coming from here?
SPEAKER 2: Sorry, the question
is to the speaker's left.
GORDON AUSTIN: Professor,
my name is Gordon Austin.
I'm a retired Naval officer
and I came from Georgia
specifically to
hear this series.
And I want to compliment
you on getting it off
to such a good start.
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Thank you.
GORDON AUSTIN: You alluded
to what my question is
at the beginning.
I recently visited
the Hermitage.
And I was struck by the
comparison between Donald Trump
and Andrew Jackson, especially
in contemporary descriptions
of Jackson.
Could you expand on that?
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Sure.
So one of the reasons
that I did write my book
was simply because there was
so much interest in Trump
being interested in Jackson.
And if you go back and
look-- so Donald Trump
gave his speech on Andrew
Jackson's 250th birthday.
And it's actually one of--
I think one of Trump's more
really well done speeches.
I don't think it would compare--
the one that he gave at the
Right to Life March was--
if we remember him
for anything, it
will be for that speech,
which was probably
written by a Hillsdale graduate,
Brittany Baldwin, most likely.
She is his speechwriter
on all things religious.
So I assume that--
she can't take credit for that,
so I will give her credit.
I'm pretty sure she's
the one who wrote that.
And amen.
But the speech he
gave on Jackson
was really quite interesting.
Now it's three years old,
coming up on three years.
And there've been
a lot of questions
about what's the similarity.
And most of the people who are
commenting on the similarities
have done so because they both
come at these populist moments,
these moments where people
are trying to take back what's
going on in Washington, DC.
There's no question-- I can't
speak as effectively on Trump.
There is no doubt that when
Andrew Jackson went to DC,
he cleaned the place up.
Andrew Jackson actually
has a squeaky clean record.
We may not always agree
with his policies.
I heard someone yell
out the Trail of Tears.
And there's no real
defensive of that.
There's an explanation,
but not a defense of it.
It's heinous.
But when we look at his actual
practices, he's squeaky clean.
We don't have
examples of corruption
in his administration at all.
And I mean, there
were things-- like, he
put in charge of all the
bureaucrats in Washington,
he put a guy in charge by
the name of Amos Kendall.
And Kendall used to walk
around from office to office.
And if he thought anybody
was wasting government time,
if they were reading
a newspaper or a novel
or if they were just
sitting there, he fired him.
You can't do this.
You're on the people's dime.
You're working or you're out.
And there's no doubt
Jackson spent his eight
years in Washington
cleaning things out.
And if I remember
correctly, he's
the only president
outside of Clinton
to have fully
balanced the budget.
And he was very
effective at this.
And a lot of it had to do with
these policies of corruption.
I don't think Trump has
been quite as effective,
but there are reasons for that.
The bureaucracy is
much deeper than it
was under Andrew Jackson.
Things were still
very politicized
under Andrew Jackson.
You either were the follower of
the president or you weren't.
And if you weren't,
you lost your job.
And it didn't matter if you
were in DC or a postal carrier,
you were out.
And so there was no
civil service tenure
other than what
the president said,
if you're in an
executive office.
The other thing that they
have in common, of course,
is they're both Scottish.
And they have that
kind of tendency,
that tendency to speak
of the cuff at times.
They also are
interesting-- and I
don't want to get too
political about this,
but, you know, when
it comes to women,
they both have interesting
relations with women.
[LAUGHTER]
But I would say Jackson's
were a lot more traditional
than Trump's have been.
So I don't want to get too much
more into detail about that,
but yeah.
So I don't know if
that answers you.
But their policies aren't that--
they're not totally
that similar.
I mean, when we
think about Jackson
being so anti-military and
so pro-free trade and so
laissez-faire.
I think Trump's been really
good on the laissez-faire part,
especially with the
regulatory offices.
But those other things--
I mean, he's clearly
not been free trade
by any means, good or bad.
He's different from
Jackson in that way.
So thank you very
much for a question.
AUDIENCE: Over here.
SPEAKER 2: Question
to the speaker.
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very
much for your talk.
In your introductory
remarks, you
talked about the
reputation of Jackson
being a rapist and
an Indian murderer.
And I really know
nothing about Jackson.
But could you talk about--
where did those stories
come from if they weren't true?
BRADLEY J BIRZER:
So a lot of them
came from his political
opponents at the time.
They used to report
things like this.
They'd have Jackson
for president,
do you want a murderer
in the White House--
things like that.
But we do remember them.
And there's no easy
defense of this.
I mean, he clearly is
responsible for the removal
of thousands upon
thousands of Indians
from their traditional
homelands to the west.
And they were removed.
If they were from
the southern states,
they were removed to Kansas--
excuse me, Oklahoma.
And from the northern
places, like here,
Hillsdale, when the
Potawatomis were moved,
they were moved to
Kansas around Topeka.
And he is responsible for that.
Now, we can look
at his arguments.
He did believe very
strongly that removal
was a preferable option to
keeping them where they were
where, where they
would keep getting
surrounded and out-populated
by those of European descent.
But the execution of
the removal was heinous.
When we look, for example,
at the Choctaw Indians, one
of the five major
tribes of the South
that was removed to Oklahoma,
when they were removed in 1831,
in 1832, they started off with
18,000 people in their tribe.
A year later, they
were down to 6,000.
They lost 2/3 of their
people in their removal.
There's no defense of that.
I think a lot of it had to do
with poor execution rather than
actual intent of the policy.
But regardless, Jackson has to
be held accountable for that,
at some level.
We have to be able
to recognize that.
Now, interestingly enough,
I mean, those people
who survived, if you
look at Indian tribes,
the Choctaws became the
single wealthiest Indian tribe
by the 1850s and 1860s.
But then, of course, they sided
with the Confederacy and--
you know, this stuff is
very, very complicated.
In fact, more Indians
owned slaves per capita
than White Americans did.
We never say that to
our children, right?
And I'm not trying to
condemn anyone in particular.
It just makes the story
really, really complicated.
There's no evidence of the rape.
I actually was--
I was on a radio show,
one of the first.
And I blew it.
I did a horrible job.
If any of you--
[LAUGHS] if any of you want
to see me do a terrible job
at something-- and hopefully
I didn't tonight on this--
if you get on--
just go onto YouTube
and do "Brad Birzer
interview Andrew Jackson."
This will pop up.
And I was horrible at it.
This guy came up.
And he said well,
Andrew Jackson's
a rapist and all this.
And I was so taken aback.
Here I'd spent all this
time writing this book.
I was like, what?
I'd not heard any of this.
So I did a quick search
of "Andrew Jackson rapist"
on Google.
And the eight of
the first 10 results
were of a rape in a public
school called the Andrew
Jackson School in Georgia.
And I don't know if
that's where it came from,
but I'm guessing, because there
was nothing in his lifetime
where anyone ever
suggested that at all.
In fact, if anything,
people made fun of him
for being so taken
with his wife.
They didn't-- actually, it was
one of those few things where
they thought Jackson
wasn't manly enough,
because his wife
commanded him around.
And she didn't command him, but
they were definitely equals.
No question.
And I wouldn't have
messed with her, either.
She was a fierce person--
devout, hardcore, Bible-thumping
Presbyterian from day one.
But you know, I
think she's amazing.
And I'm shocked there
aren't more books about her.
And she was very liberally
educated, actually,
and a great writer.
So I can't believe--
I don't know why people
haven't written about her.
They should.
She's a great person.
So I hope that answers you.
Yeah, thank you.
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for one more question.
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Dr. Birzer.
My question is-- it's about
General Jackson rallying troops
to defend New Orleans,
with the recent purchase
of the Louisiana Territory
under the Jefferson presidency.
What did General
Jackson have to do
to win the support of the locals
of New Orleans, especially
with the change in loyalties?
BRADLEY J BIRZER: Right.
So you know, it's
very interesting.
We don't-- there
are a lot of things.
We have a lot of good evidence
about what he did there.
And I would really recommend--
in my book on Jackson,
I only spend about
four pages on this.
I think it's really important,
but I just kind of get
at the mythical element.
If any of you are interested,
this Fox News correspondent,
Brian Kilmeade, has written a
book on Jackson at New Orleans.
And I think it's
an excellent book.
It is very well researched
and beautifully written.
And he deals exactly with this.
So I don't want to defer--
I don't want to not
answer your question,
but really, if you
want to look at that,
I think he's probably the best
of current writers dealing
with that.
But Jackson, I mean,
there is no doubt
that there was some opposition
to what he was doing,
especially--
Jackson, he walked into town.
It's basically his town.
He comes in with his
militia, and they're not
even from that area.
Remember, these are
Tennessee guys, right?
But he's able to recruit
some people within the area.
But he mostly tells the
citizens of New Orleans
just to stay away.
He doesn't want them near the
battle, on his side or out.
He wants his men,
whom he can trust.
And by the way, just to
get to the question that
was asked a moment ago,
it is very interesting.
Andrew Jackson's
army was made up--
it was mostly white Tennesseans.
But about a third of it was
freed Blacks and Indians,
who were his allies.
Again, it's one of those things
we don't often talk about.
It's a motley crew.
It's an interesting-- and he
even recruits some pirates very
famously--
John La Feet from the area--
who decide to fight with him.
And do it very success--
they're very successful at this.
But Jackson more or less puts--
it's not official,
but he more or less
puts New Orleans under
martial law during the time.
He can't regulate it.
It's something he just has
to depend that they'll do.
But he basically tells
them, don't bother with us,
we won't bother with you.
And of all the people-- there
are crazy stories that come out
of this miracle at New Orleans.
But one group of--
if you think about it,
these are French and Spanish
who are living there.
The people who
help him the most,
there's a convent of nuns
there who, for whatever reason,
think Andrew Jackson
is this great guy.
And I'm guessing he
treated them pretty well.
And they were running
food to the poor
and taking care of things
while he was not in town.
And I had nuns in grade school.
They can be wonderful,
and they can be fierce.
And I'm sure I'm sure martial
law would have been preferable.
[LAUGHTER]
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, everyone.